let's go next to our caller from the
for10 area code who's calling today from
four one zero hi David I believe that me
yes it is okay this is Andrew can you
hear me I can what kind of a device do
you have a son because it sounds weird
Andrew I'm not gonna lie okay how about
now it's much better yes okay perfect
I had a question that now that the q3
finance information about several
campaigns has come out I was wondering
if your analysis or predictions have
changed at all about the yang campaign
I'm kind of undecided but the
exponential growth was kind of shocking
to me I didn't expect him to reach
double digits so I was wondering if you
had any thoughts on that
he reached double digits in what in
terms of the millions he just announced
that he they raised 10 million for q3
double-digit polling yeah I mean listen
you know he's a good campaign he's
running a good campaign
I don't until there's that one Emerson
poll that says yang has 8% no other poll
says that if we start seeing more polls
that say that then I will start to
believe it like I don't have any
particular insight into this is what
we're seeing in terms of fundraising
this is what we're seeing in terms of
polling this is what we're seeing in
terms of debate performance and we're
all kind of in it together trying to
figure it out but he's certainly running
a solid campaign right definitely I'm
curious to see how these increased
numbers if it changes the polling at all
because I know he's yet to really break
above 3% nationally on average yeah so
we'll see how it goes but thank you I
appreciate your insight alright thank
you for the call I appreciate it